hey guys what's up I'm Ilana and welcome
to my Channel today I'm going to be
talking about until dawn which is an
upcoming survival horror for the ps4
that I got to play at eb expo this year
but apparently not a lot of people have
heard of it it's a ps4 exclusive being
developed by a supermassive games so it
was originally supposed to be a ps3 move
title but got pushed forward to the ps4
I described it as being a cheesy horror
movie slasher flick kind of like scream
but with some strong gameplay parallels
to heavy rain and some kind of choice
based stuff like the sole franchise it's
it's a unique thing until dawn is like
being able to participate in one of
those horror movies so a bunch of kind
of annoying teenagers go away for a
weekend for the anniversary of one of
their friends debts to some super
secluded log place and up in a house
with a super brutal super creepy serial
killer and I kind of love the idea it's
cheesy it's kind of over-the-top and
it's easy to make jokes about who you
want to die but it is a little hard I
want to get to the point that some of
them actually do yeah the demo I played
ended up with serial killer actually
finding me and then there was this q te
sequence and even though i passed the
QTE sequence he just knocked me out
anyway so they're the two characters
that I was kind of playing as woke up in
this room I was sitting on a desk with a
camcorder on them and they're both tied
up two chairs and there's a gun in the
middle of the table there's a soul on
the ceiling that's slowly moving down
and you have to shoot one of them so you
play as the male character in this one
and grab the gun at shoot yourself or
shoot the girl otherwise the soul will
come down and kill both of you I shot
the girl because she was really annoying
she's kind of one of the ones that you
wished would die straight away I think
and then the demo ended and I just
thought that was so cool but I was also
annoyed that it ended like how did the
guy get out of it did the serial killer
end up coming and getting him anyway or
did some of the other people who were
still alive come and rescue the guy like
how how did he get out of that room as
well so i think that the premise is
awesome and totally fun and pretty
unique even though it's it's pretty
messed up but i think the controls are
going to put a lot of people off the
camera angles are fixed like heavy rain
and if you haven't played heavy rain
there are actually three videos of me
playing it on my channel here if you
want to see what it's like now that's
not so much of an issue just something
that's actually worth explain it yeah
to a problem is that you control a lot
of the game with the PlayStation control
up by kind of moving it so you
physically tilt your controller to
control a torch and to interact with
some things in the game and the motion
controls are a little bit inaccurate
that could be because the game isn't
finished yet but I find personally that
regardless anytime that I have to do
this it just feels kind of shoddy and
unnatural and I would prefer to be able
to control things just like a normal
third person game now I don't think this
is an outright floor it's just enough to
put off some people that I think it's a
bad thing I'm sure some people will have
a lot of fun with it what that said I
really enjoyed my time playing this game
and I think it was one of the demos that
I was so caught up in it that I was
really disappointed when it did end I'm
just weirdly excited by this popular
movie genre which I seem to spend a lot
of time when I watch these like teenage
horror flicks like being annoyed at
people for doing dumb things and making
jokes about how stupid they are it just
ends up being like this really fun thing
even though things are kind of creepy as
well I think it's gonna be a great game
to play with like a group of friends and
it totally believably made this genre of
movies into a game they made it totally
cinematic the characters were kind of
annoying the situation was just
ridiculous and over the top but despite
the use of kind of annoying cuties and
fixed cameras and kind of awkward
controls I was having so much fun
playing it that it was kind of easy to
forget that those walls were there even
with all of the jump-scares which I
absolutely hate until dawn is set to
release some time in 2015 exclusively on
the playstation 4 i'm alana thank you
for watching and I'll see you guys next
time